hey everybody International master David
proofs here for chess calm and today
we're just going to go over a really
important special move in chess there
aren't too many of these on there is
ALPA soul which is a special way to
capture with pawns another video covers
that and there is castling which is
really a very very valuable move so good
to know which is a way that you can sort
of reverse the position of your king and
your rook
so castling is useful because usually
your king will be in some danger in the
center of the board and your books will
be somewhat useless outside of the
center of the board so you'll want to
sort of reverse that situation you're
allowed to make this move only if
there's no piece in between your king
and rook and you can do it towards the
Kings side or towards the Queen side now
the basic rule for castling is you move
your King two steps towards the rook and
put the rook on the other side of your
king so for example we would move this
King to G 1 and then the rook jumps to F
1 or if we do it in the other direction
again you move two spaces even though
you won't end up at the same spot and
the rook hops to the other side of the
king always the rook ends up next to
your king ok so black will also Castle
queenside versus King two steps and the
road comes to the other side of his king
okay so that's the basic rule of
castling that's what it looks like when
you castle now there are a couple side
rules to realize in addition to not
having anything in between your king and
rook you need to not violate certain
rules about check which is when your
king is attacked okay so let's say that
black played this checking move with the
Queen white is not allowed to castle
when their king is in check so this is
not a legal way to escape from check to
move your King two spaces to g1 you
would now have to move your King to
avoid this check okay now second rule
about castling you cannot castle
through checks so since black controls
the F ones where white is not allowed to
Castle kingside here though he could
Castle queenside and the final rule is
that you can't castle onto a square
where you would be in check so here the
black queen has moved so she's covering
c1 that means white cannot Castle
queenside that would be illegal to put
your king in check okay so three rules
for when you cannot Castle you can't
Castle when you are in check
you can't castle through check and you
can't castle into check okay and sorry
but there's more you are not allowed to
castle if you've already moved your king
or your rook so remember when black
checked the white king this would
actually in this case since white can't
block or capture the Queen this would
prevent white from ever castling because
now the white king has moved so he's no
longer allowed to castle so black checks
the white king again the white king
moves and now black castles to get their
ropes into the game now is white allowed
to castle either side the answer is no
because the King has already moved
alright now here's another example let's
go back to the beginning here I'll play
h3 for white black plays Queen takes b2
attacking this rook and I move the rook
to save it now black castles am I
allowed to Castle kingside now even
though I've moved this rook I can
because this is not the rook that I'm
castling with so I can Castle kingside
but let's say instead of castling black
had retreated his queen and I moved my
rook back here and now black castled
would I be allowed to Castle queenside
absolutely not because this rook has
moved okay so I can't Castle queenside
but I can Castle kingside but one
restriction which does not apply just to
be clear is this if black plays this
move attacking the rook is white allowed
to Castle queenside this is from my
starting position so the King
hasn't moved the king is not in check
the rook hasn't moved the rook is
attacked the answer is I can Castle
queenside seed because I never put my
King on a square that was attacked by
the black Queen so it is legal to castle
when your rook is attacked but not once
you've moved your rook and those are the
rules for castling I hope you enjoyed
this video and I'll see you around on
chess calm